on parle des olympiades à présent dans
cette chronique aux sports oui ce
week-end il c'est la quatrième édition
des olympiades du vivre ensemble à
versailles samedi précisément au stade
mon bout rond et pour en parler
évidemment une des organisatrices si ce
n'est de l'organisatrice annick bouquay
conseillère municipale chargée des
sports à la ville de versailles bonsoir
à vous bonsoir alors expliquez moi un
petit peu le concept de ces olympiades
du vivre ensemble alors je vais revenir
à l'histoire il ya à peu près dans les
années 65 70 ce professeur lejeune avait
initié justement une rencontre de
surtout du handicap mental au stade de
montberon qui je sais que ça a eu un
grand succès et puis ça a été repris par
monsieur port au trac et asmar adjoint
aux sports la delà la présidente de
l'adapei a voulu relancer le sujet et le
maire m'a confié cette mission et j'ai
plutôt eu envie de l'ouvrir justement
aux valides et non valides et pourquoi
je les ai appelés les olympiades vivre
ensemble parce que je suis convaincu que
le handicap va nous apprendre à remettre
la notion du vivre ensemble parce que ça
nous oblige à s'adapter à l'autre on
peut pas mentir un handicapé on va pas
lui dire grimpe alors qu'il n'est pas
capable de grimper ça nous oblige à
aller à l'essentiel ça nous apprend
aussi l'humilité et donc c'est cette
journée elle est aussi pour ça donc ces
olympiades en fin de compte ce sont des
valides qui vont pouvoir venir à la
rencontre de
deux personnes handicapées sur des
ateliers sportifs sports collectifs
football et c'est exactement ce et
j'essaie qu'un équilibre entre justement
le nom de valider de nom de non valides
quel que soit le handicap qui soit
mental physique ou autres parce que déjà
je pars du principe qu'on est tous
quelque part on a peut-être une habilité
invalidité quelque part et puis c'est
pareil au niveau des associations
sportives qui contribuent à cette
journée qui est aussi d association
handisport comme des associations ne
valide parce qu'un des buts aussi c'est
que les associations de on va dire de
valides cessons sportifs valides puisse
intégrer si cela est possible certains
enfants liés au handicap et on va en
parler justement après de cette
intégration des personnes handicapées
dans les clubs notamment l'année
dernière il y avait eu à peu près 1000
participants donc c'est un événement qui
connaît dieu un bon succès et parmi tous
ces valides qui viennent à la rencontre
de ces personnes handicapées quelles
sont leurs réactions il ya des préjugés
qui tombe un petit peu je sais pas s'ils
viennent avec des préjugés parce que de
toute façon quand ils viennent ils
savent qu'ils vont avoir du vent être en
fait avait mélangé avec des gens
handicapés mais le constat que je puisse
faire c'est que vraiment c'est que du
sourire que de la joie que du bonheur je
redirai un exemple qui a été assez
marquant c'est qu'il y avait un atelier
où il y avait un enfant très très
lourdement handicapé cave envie de
participer il y avait des petits jeunes
qui avaient monopolisé cet atelier parce
qu'elle avait un trampoline et on
pouvait sauter donc c'était
extraordinaire et quand il à
l'animatrice sera délaissé le faire et
donc l'ont laissé faire et surtout ils
se sont pas du tout mot clé de cet
enfant décapite avait vraiment beaucoup
de mal et vraiment le cadeau final c'est
qu'ils ont applaudi très très fort et
qu'ils ont pris avec lui l'ont intégré
dans le groupe et puis ils sont partis
pour la journée comme ça c'est souvent
une journée où il ya de belles
rencontres et de belgique voilà et
beaucoup de bonne humeur beaucoup parce
que le handicap créé et de la bonne
humeur alors vous me parliez tout à
l'heure de
2 c'était fort justement de favoriser
l'insertion des personnes handicapées
dans les clubs sportifs c'est quelque
chose qui est difficile encore à l'heure
actuelle particulièrement sur versailles
où ça se fait petit à petit alors je
sais pas si je ne vends pas là pas de
mois difficiles je dirai seulement que
c'était pas quelque chose qui existe est
donc
je pense que les gens ne pensais pas
qu'il pouvait avoir des ponts entre puis
c'est vrai que l'handicap élargirait que
tout le monde ne peuvent pas intégrer et
puis ça dépend du des sports et mais je
pense que cette journée voilà permet de
voir que certains handicaps c'est
possible de les intégrer et puis même du
côté handicapé c'est pas seulement du
côté valide qu' il ya des des idées
prétention il ya aussi du côté
handicapés quelles sont les idées
préconçues justement du côté handicapé
il pense qu'il n'a pas sa place aussi au
sein de des personnes valides c'est
évident donc cette journée s'est fait
justement pour faire tomber les
barrières et puis surtout enlever les
panneaux qu'on a dans son dos et devenir
tel qu'on est comme c'est la quatrième
édition il ya eu des résultats positifs
avec les précédentes éditions oui parce
que chaque année on augmente cette année
on a ne serait ce qu'au niveau des
foyers parce que ça vient de partout ça
vient de beaucoup des yvelines mais en a
qui viennent de paris du 92
d'eure-et-loir club aussi ont commencé à
intégrer ses parents restés situation de
handicap tout doucement oui ils sont ils
commencent à être plus en plus ouvert
voilà vous en parlait justement de
partenariat qui commençait à se faire en
basket handball qui berce exactement ça
progresse petit à petit les captive tout
à les mentalités évoluent exactement et
alors que va-t-on pouvoir faire du coup
si will fall et moi avons envie de venir
samedi rencontrée un peu de tactique
d'actifs connectivité plein alors le
matin et à la natation il ya de la
plongée et à iliad équitation et puis
surtout après tout le long de la journée
il ya du basket du chambard à de l'
escalade à la liste extrêmement long du
run bike
l'annulation cécifoot aussi je crois
maladie cécifoot par valentin die
la ligue du judo qui font un atelier
aussi formidable il ya tout ce qu'ils
les sports collectifs en fauteuil à
partir de quelle heure c'est de 9h à 17h
c'est toute la journée on pique nique
tous ensemble et à des plateaux repas
gratuits pour les bénévoles et à la fin
tout le monde un goûter voilà merci
beaucoup a ni d'être venu sur le plateau
de télé filet rendez vous samedi de 9h à
verser en plaisir merci